außenpolitik großes thema vor dem berg
was mich in dieser woche beschäftigen
ich habe schon gesagt ich habe eine art
vermisst ich war in afghanistan
unterwegs in der vergangenen woche dort
war ich im vergangenen jahr sehr häufig
unter anderem kurz nachdem die taliban
übernommen haben und davor und ich war
in dieser woche in einem frauengefängnis
in herat wir sind da rein gekommen warum
uns die taliban der reingelassen haben
habe ich auch nicht ganz verstanden sie
waren irgendwie stolz darauf und zu
zeigen dass das system in dem sie leben
total gut funktioniert und wie
funktioniert das ist es so haben uns
aktivisten gesagt wenn man als frau dort
über die straße geht zum beispiel ein
mann falsch anschaut wenn man eine
textnachricht schreibt an jemanden und
land checkpoint kontrolliert wird dann
landet man dort in dem gefängnis das sie
dort gerade sehen verschleierte frauen
die verschämt auf den boden schauen die
nicht wissen was mit ihrem leben
passieren könnte sie werden ausgeteilt
das haben uns taliban bestätigt
aktivistinnen sagen auch dass vielen von
ihnen die todesstrafe droht nämlich die
steinigung und was sagte uns dort eine
aufseherin naja wenn sie single sein
dann könnten sie ja den mann heiraten
den sie dort getroffen haben dann kämen
sie frei wenn das nicht der fall sein
dann müsste der ehemann über diese
strafe entscheiden wahnsinns zustände
die mich wirklich erschüttert haben und
ich sage wird dürfen diese frauen nicht
vergessen vor allem unsere neue
bundesregierung dafür ein in vielen
krisen diese auf dieser welt gibt
ukraine russland ist das was uns
momentan beschäftigt aber auch
afghanistan nicht vergessen und deswegen
ist es für uns wichtig dort immer wieder
hin zu schauen darauf hinzuweisen wie es
diesen frauen in afghanistan geht und
ich habe große sorge dass viele von
ihnen in ein paar monaten nicht mehr
leben können dann die große sorge die
ich da habe ist dass viele menschen wenn
sie die bilder sehen da ist eine
verschleierte frau sieht alles anders
aus ich habe nicht so richtig die
beziehung die ich zu diesen bildern
aufbauen kann dass man vergisst dass das
frauen und menschen dort sind die die
gleichen ängste haben wie wir wenn wir
in der situation werden und ich war auch
viel im ausland und das braucht man
manchmal wirklich wahrhaftig da gewesen
zu sein um zu verstehen worum es geht
das kann jetzt nicht jeder ich finde es
bewundernswert dass sie da hinfahren
dass sie diese bilder machen das ist ja
auch nicht ohne risiko aber ich würde an
jeden verlieren lassen sie mal zu hause
diese bilder zu lassen sie mal zu wie
sich das für sie anfühlen würde dass man
nicht sagt ja aber die haben ja auch
also man versuche
selbstständig ich habe inzwischen wieder
die reaktionen bekommen wenn ich
sozusagen über afghanistan berichtet
habe dann wurde mir gesagt ja aber in
deutschland gibt es auch große probleme
warum berichten sie über afghanistan und
berichten sie lieber über corona dem
muss ich gar nicht leiden menschliche
reagiert weil wir das einleitende an uns
ranlassen wollen dann wird
rationalisiert dann wird abgelenkt weil
also ich finde es ist eigentlich nicht
ertragbar die bilder zu sehen und sich
einmal rein zu führen das ist warum wir
auch mit der eigenen geschichte so viel
schwierigkeiten haben uns auseinander zu
setzen weiß weh tut und das ist etwas
was vielleicht auch jetzt in der
vorweihnachtszeit mal wichtig ist dass
man auch mal gefühle an sich ran das ist
geht nicht immer nur um geldspenden
sondern einmal mitfühlen mit anderen und
da finde ich diesen bericht ich fand den
unglaublich stark weil er bei mir auch
ganz viel ausgelöst hat und wenn man mal
dran denkt wie würde ich mich dem film
wenn meine mutter da sitzt meine
schwester meine ehefrau dass man tut das
immer so schnell ab das ist etwas das
die menschen sind aus dem gleichen
fleisch und blut wie wir die gleichen
gefühle und leiden unglaublich ich finde
es ein ganz wichtiger punkt weil was ich
auch bei den bildern 1100 war ich war
danach auch auf social media und dann
sind da natürlich immer die ganzen
feministin post wie rolf feministin
diese in diese ganze für mich ist es der
lifestyle feminismus und dann werdet ihr
in deutschland ja auch dauernd gibt es
ja auch viel mehr portman events oder
die frauen die es eh schon geschafft
haben zusammensitzen mit rosa törtchen
und erzählen die gleichberechtigung
schaffen und damit ich hoffen dass man
die ganzen frauen in deutschland die
sich als feministin bezeichnen und damit
ja auch entweder geld verdienen oder das
als ihr lebensmotto begreifen dass sie
vielleicht mal nach afghanistan schauen
und das empfinde ich bei den bildern da
sieht man nämlich wirklich wo feminismus
gebraucht wird und da muss ich sagen
nachdem ich erst die tolle reportage von
der gesehen habe bei bild und dann durch
social media des kreuzenden bin ich
wahnsinnig wütend geworden auf die
gesellschaft ich finde zum einen bei
allem was da schief gegangen ist und das
wollen wir ja auch überprüfen evaluieren
mit diesem afghanistan-einsatz straff
das trotzdem diejenigen lügen die immer
vorher zynisch gesagt haben das bringt
alles nichts dieser einsatz natürlich
hat es für jedes mädchen das zur schule
gehen konnte und dass ein paar jahre in
einer anderen situation leben konnte
sehr wohl was gebracht und es ist so
bitter dass das jetzt so schnell wieder
verloren ist diese kleinen erfolge die
aber für jeden jeder einzelne frau jedes
einzelne mädchen so wichtig sind und ich
finde ganz wichtig dass wir das auch
nicht gegeneinander ausspielen übrigens
wir müssen genauso in anderen teilen der
welt hin schauen wir müssen damit will
und ich finde auch wichtig allerdings
dass das macht mir oft sorge dass bei
uns manche sich auch übrigens zu leicht
tun dann zb die verschleierung oder das
kopftuch zu verharmlosen und so zurück
in deutschland als nicht jetzt hätte das
nicht was mit unterdrückung von frauen
zu tun weil ich denke zum beispiel auch
an die mutigen frauen im iran die
versuchen zu zeigen dass sie dieses
kopftuch nicht tragen wollen dass sie
ein selbst bestimmtes leben führen
wollen und dafür viel riskieren und dass
wir dass wir das auch nicht hier mit so
einer seltsam einstellungen hier zu
einem zu freiheits zeichen verklären
sondern dass wir beides sehen es gibt
sehr unterschiedliche gefährdung von
frauenrechten in verschiedenen teilen
der welt aber jeder ist ernst zu nehmen
jetzt hat frau berbalk ja den begriff
geprägt dass sie eine feministische
außenpolitik machen möchte was glauben
sie was das bedeutet wird oder was
hoffen sie was das bedeutet sind ich
hoffe mal das wäre für mich jetzt die
die find ich vernünftige liberale
sichtweise dass frauenrechte sind
menschenrechte und deshalb sollten wir
uns für die natürlich einsetzen sowie
für die rechte von jedem menschen was
mir dabei aber generell wichtig ist dass
es ja nicht reicht eine gesinnung starke
rhetorik zu haben sondern man muss auch
seine verantwortungs ethischen ziele mit
harten fähigkeiten unterlegen und da
wird es dann spannend sind wir
eigentlich verteidigungs fähig sind
bleiben wir wirtschaftlich stark um von
den autokraten und diktatoren dieser
welt ernst genommen zu werden um durch
auch durch abschreckungspotenzial den
frieden zu bewahren und da glaube ich
wird es spannend da muss man draußen bei
uns bei der wirtschaftspolitik nicht zu
hart da hingeht das ist ja in der in der
diplomatie so verstehe ich das zumindest
ist es ja immer so wenn ich jetzt total
überzeugt und wohin geht es gibt diesen
einspruch only nixon oder joysticks mit
dem gutschein also nur welchen hardliner
bin kann ich da auch paroli bieten ich
glaube dass das heute so nicht mehr
funktioniert und dass wir deutschen auch
zum glück anders wahrgenommen werden in
der welt unser verhandlungsgeschick ist
sehr gefragt aber wir haben zusammen mit
den anderen in afghanistan können das
eigentlich gesagt immer nur so
wahrgenommen werden als die deutschen
weil wir im hintergrund amerikanischen
armeen haben soldaten haben oder eine
amerikanische armee die extrem
leistungsfähig ist anders könnten ja
unter den teppich unter den füßen
wegziehen kann das ist ja wenn ich wenn
ich jetzt mal ganz platt gesagt dieses
land einnehmen will dann ist mir die
geschichte erst mal egal also wenn ich
dieses land verteidigen möchte die
freiheit von 80 millionen deutschen dann
steht erstmal die frei von 80 millionen
deutschen auf dem spiel und die kann ich
verteidige ich kann sie nicht verteilen
dafür brauche ich am ende immer eine
schlagwaffe muss man ja sagen dass wir
deutsche in afghanistan verteidigt haben
und das hat ja nicht jeder so gesehen
wir haben über den punkt gesprochen über
den punkt gesprochen was bedeutet das
eigentlich was sind auch lehren daraus
immer die frage kann ich jetzt
afghanistan befrieden kann ich die
verschleierten frauen aus dem knast
retten und kann ich auch dafür sorgen
dass sie wieder in freiheit leben das
wird mutmaßlich mit blick auf die
nächsten jahre schwierig aber der punkt
in linda teuteberg er machte ist dass
wir von diesen bedrohungen überall auf
der welt eigentlich mittlerweile hören
und auch viel sehen und die gefahr ja
auch durchaus wenn man jetzt nach
osteuropa schaut nicht so ganz weit weg
von unserer tür ist wenn man auf das
säbelrasseln gerade das ja gar nicht so
viel gelesen werden wir gucken immer auf
uns es wird ganz viel über die deutsche
politik berichtet über deutsche problem
auch indische zeitungen wird vielmehr
darin besteht dass mir das schwimmen in
dem fall ich also die afghanischen
frauen tatsächlich hat viele bewegt
insbesondere in der bild am sonntag bei
bild.de sehr sehr viele menschen die
daran teilgenommen haben
das ist sehr unterschiedlich muss man
sagen ich glaube es kommt auch sehr
darauf an welchen focus man auch als
reporter nimmt und wie sehr man die
dinge so zu sagen auf den punkt bringen
kann oder eben nicht nicht immer leicht
man hat natürlich nicht viel zugang
immer den man sich wünscht als reporter
aber gerade wenn wir jetzt an die
situation denken an der grenze ukraine
russland aber auch übrigens das thema
belarus grenze zu polen litauen dann
kann man auch sind ja manche schnell
dabei die falschen schlüsse zu ziehen
also ich finde gerade aus unserer
geschichte sollten wir den schluss
ziehen dass wir nie wieder über die über
unsere nachbarn hinweg über die länder
die übrigens ganz besonders gelitten
haben unter vereinbarungen zwischen
deutschland und russland sowohl reden
wollen genau dass wir nicht über deren
köpfe hinweg politik machen sondern dass
wir zu unseren verpflichtungen stehen in
der nato in der eben dass sich auch
polen und litauer zum beispiel darauf
verlassen können dass wir ihre
sicherheit mit schützen und auch dass
unsere gemeinsame außengrenze ist bei
den debatten deutschland kann man
manchmal den eindruck haben dass er den
polen die vorwürfe gemacht werden oder
dass man nicht so gerne dazu steht dass
wir auch eine verpflichtung haben in der
nato unsere verpflichtungen zu erfüllen
das kostet auch geld und das bedeutet
auch militärische fähigkeiten aufzubauen
und nicht immer dass die anderen den job
machen müssen und wir sind die
diplomaten beides gehört zusammen die
würden dann europäische armee eine
lösung also so in der politik wie wird
das ich war ja das höre und da wo ist
einmal das kommt nie wo ich denke aber
das ist doch für die die jetzt jungen
nachwachsen man sieht doch gar nicht
mehr so deutschland ich sehe mich als
europäer auch nicht aber das wurde jahre
jahrzehnte versuche ich das glauben wenn
wir uns anschauen also das ende meiner
grundfrage nicht ob wir uns damit
beschäftigen was unsere verantwortung
wir sind wir bereit dafür zu tun und
insofern übrigens haben wir auch die
amerikaner nicht unrecht trotz ihrer
eigenen interessen bei dem nord stream
thema unabhängig von dem 19 großes thema
vor sollte bei was wir ganz sicher in
der nächsten sendung besprechen werden